on va passer désormais à notre second
débat alors c'est un mâle qui ronge
notre société les Français sont de plus
en plus nombreux à remettre en cause la
parole scientifique cette crise de
confiance elle ne date pas d'hier mais
elle a été considérablement renforcée
par la crise covid on a eu ce développer
tout un tas de théories soit farfelues
soit complotiste soit carrément des fake
news alors contre la vaccination
notamment alors comment on peut remédier
on peut soigner ce mal et redonner du
crédit à la parole de nos chercheurs de
nos médecins comment on ramène de la
raison et des arguments dans des débats
ou règne souvent la suspicion ou
l'invective et bien on va faire
l'autopsie d'une défiance dangereuse sur
la démocratie c'est un sujet de Jonathan
Dupriez
vous êtes déjà venu chez nous dans cet
officine parisienne on ne se bouscule
pas au portillon pour se faire vacciner
contre la grippe saisonnière c'est une
petite une petite aiguille indolore les
gens se sentent quasiment rien encore
faut-il avoir des patients car la
campagne hépatine - 20 % de doses
injectées par rapport à l'année dernière
sur la même période soit 1 million
600000 vaccins de moins que l'année
passée il y a une certaine défiance sur
la vaccination un ras-le-bol tout le
monde a un avis sur tout le monde est
venu virologue une défiance des doutes
que la pandémie semble avoir exacerbée
face aux inquiétudes des Français les
scientifiques ont été sur sollicités et
utilisés par le monde politique pour
tâtonner dans la crise au risque
d'embrouiller les messages
de la part des instances
gouvernementales des allers-retours qui
était un peu douteux
se laissent avoir avec des Raoul des des
médecins à la qui veulent se faire de la
publicité sur le sujet les enquêtes
d'opinion semblent plutôt rassurantes
une série d'études réalisées sur 30 ans
par le CNRS montre une confiance élevée
en la science près de 9 Français sur dix
croix en elle un résultat flatteur mais
qui pour certaines figures du monde
scientifique ne suffit pas à mettre la
matière à l'abri des remises en question
qui est une fable de Jean-Pierre
Clarisse de Florian Catherine Brechignac
est une physicienne de renom membre de
l'Académie des Sciences sur le pont Neuf
entouré de badauds un charlatan criait à
pleine tête venez messieurs à court et
faire en tête de grands remèdes à tous
les mots vite je m'approchais pour voir
ce beau trésor c'était un peu de poudre
d'or
voilà que ça signifie cette cette fin
cette fable mais justement ça veut dire
que que vous vous faites avoir par des
par des charlatans dans son dernier
ouvrage elle s'inquiète de la montée en
puissance des récits alternatifs et
autres théories complotistes face à une
vérité scientifique plus vulnérable que
jamais la science c'était un protocole
qu'on construit petit à petit comme on
construit une maison avec des briques et
on l'a mise au niveau de l'opinion et
en fait on a plus plus rien pour se
raccrocher à quelque chose qui conduit à
la vérité je crois qu'il faut informer
il faut éduquer il faut apprendre à aux
gens et aux jeunes surtout à reprendre
le questionnement
informé éduquer le CNRS en a fait l'un
des axes de sa communication le plus
grand institut de recherche français a
créé en 2017 une chaîne Youtube pour
mieux expliquer ses travaux au grand
public
des chercheurs de la région parisienne
se sont intéressés à la modélisation
mathématique des mouvements de foule et
l'équipe en charge du programme vient
d'inaugurer son nouveau studio alors là
c'est le studio où on tourne les
épisodes d'une de nos séries qui
s'appelle un S pour la planète qui est
consacré essentiellement à des
thématiques qui sont liées à
l'environnement et donc on fait grosso
modo un tournage tous les mois et demi
ici avec des sujets concernant autant
accrocheurs le CNRS entend vulgariser la
science sans pour autant compromettre sa
rigueur il y a quand même un mouvement
de défiance envers la science qu'on a vu
notamment autour du covid la crise du
covid et qui montre qu'il y a vraiment
un besoin de donner de l'information qui
soit fiable de sortir un peu de
l'aridité des publications scientifiques
et de donner une sorte d'attractivité
quand même à ce qu'on raconte c'est de
sortir un peu des tours d'ivoire des
labos et de montrer que la science c'est
extrêmement important mais surtout c'est
passionnant en fait et la stratégie
semble payer la chaîne compte
aujourd'hui 45 000 abonnés et près d'un
million 500 000 vues pour l'ensemble de
ses vidéos l'idée c'était de les capter
leur attention les intéresser des
émerveillés avec les sujets de science
et puis de leur montrer qu'en fait la
science elle est partout elle est dans
leur téléphone elle est autour d'eux
dans la nature et que la science en fait
elle concerne tous les grands enjeux
aujourd'hui changement climatiques
l'énergie avec plus de 80 vidéos déjà
produites le CNRS planche sur de
nouveaux projets pour expliquer la
science l'institut de recherche pourrait
se pencher sur l'histoire des sciences
sans de futurs programmes pour le web
alors arrow sur la science ou plutôt
comment réhabiliter la science et la
parole scientifique on en parle ce soir
avec mes invités bonsoir Anne Senequier
vous êtes médecin chercheur à l'Iris
auteur de la géopolitique tout
simplement avec Pascal Boniface aux
éditions Hérolles j'accueille à vos
côtés pierre ouzouglias bonsoir sénateur
communiste des Hauts-de-Seine
vice-président de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication ici donc au Sénat et votre
voix compte double si j'ose dire ce soir
puisque vous êtes aussi archéologue et
chargé de recherche au CNRS trois
maisons voilà Olivier lascar est
également avec nous vous êtes rédacteur
en chef du pôle digital de Sciences et
Avenir auteur de enquête sur Elon Musk
l'homme qui défilé la science aux
éditions Alizée aux sciences et puis
bien sûr Émilie appelle ski qui est
resté avec moi et qui reste jusqu'à la
fin de l'émission alors on va parler du
covid on va parler des vaccins on va
parler du complotisme tout ça mais
d'abord une question toute simple est-ce
que les Français ont perdu confiance en
la science et aux olias alors c'est plus
que la science je pense que il y a une
forme de défiance vis-à-vis de l'idée
même du progrès le progrès a été
constitutif de l'idéal républicain toute
la Troisième République
il y a eu beaucoup de gouvernements dans
lesquels il y avait des savants ce qui
est plus le cas aujourd'hui il y a eu au
Parlement beaucoup de savants ce qui est
moins le cas aussi aujourd'hui vous
savez qu'on est on est deux chercheurs
au CNRS dans l'hémicycle au Sénas qui ce
qui montre que il y a un fossé qui tout
doucement s'est creusé entre le savant
et le et le politique et tout ça
participe d'une défiance vis-à-vis de
toutes les institutions mais notamment
de l'institution scientifique en effet
alors je vous donne quelques chiffres
selon la grande enquête nationale les
Français et la science une majorité de
français pour être précis 62% en 2020
déclarait que la recherche par exemple
apporte autant de bien que de mal et
c'est une spécificité hexagonale
oui moi je dirais qu'il y a toujours une
appétence terrible pour les sciences et
quand on est moi je suis rédacteur en
chef par exemple d'un site qui au
quotidien cartographies l'actualité des
sciences c'est le site de sciences et à
venir il est animé par des journalistes
et on se rend compte vu la force de
frappe qu'on a sur les réseaux sociaux
on a plus de 2 millions de fans sur
Facebook par exemple donc la République
c'est considérable il y a un public il y
a une vraie curiosité scientifique en
revanche le changement effectivement
c'est que je pense que jadis la science
était adossée à des figures quasiment
mythiques mythologiques comme Louis
Pasteur Marie Curie c'est-à-dire des
personnes qui avaient un rapport
désincarné à la science c'est-à-dire qui
travaillait pour l'intérêt du public et
uniquement du public et on pensait que
la science c'était quelque chose qui ne
pouvait générer que du bien et
aujourd'hui il y a se glissement vers
une situation où on se dit que comme
vous le disiez autant de bien que de mal
voire peut-être quelquefois avec le
développement des technosciences avec le
développement de l'industrie et des
sujets dont on va vous parler du mal
peut
inquiétudes mais là ça aime génère des
interrogations sur la finalité de la
recherche scientifique au fond oui oui
la finalité oui effectivement mais cette
ce mouvement de fond il vient aussi du
fait qu'il y a on manque d'une pédagogie
non pas simplement des sciences mais de
ce qu'est la méthode scientifique et la
méthode scientifique c'est quelque chose
de très spécifique et ça ça n'a pas
encore percuté dans l'esprit du public
que la science elle ne se fait pas comme
ça d'un claquement de doigts la méthode
scientifique ce sont des chercheurs qui
travaillent dans des labos une fois que
leur expérimentation leur manipulation
sont faites elles sont vérifiées
validées par d'autres scientifiques
c'est la fameuse validation par les paix
et une fois que cette validation elle
est faite les articles sont publiés dans
la presse scientifique mais la presse
spécialisée science nature the landset
dont on a beaucoup parlé on va y venir
alors je vous donne un autre chiffre
selon une étude sur leur selon l'étude
sur le développement de l'esprit
critique des Français en 2021 c'est une
grande étude qui a été menée auprès de
plus de 3000 personnes pour universion
ce point fr 53% des Français estiment
que les théories scientifiques sont des
théories parmi d'autres alors attendez
accrochez-vous votre siège seul 27%
considère qu'on ne peut pas remettre en
cause un fait scientifique ça c'est
inquiétant quand même un Séné qui est
non c'est vrai qu'on est parti de la
science et on est arrivé dans la
croyance et la croyance et je peux y
croire où je peux ne pas y croire et ça
ça devient problématique puisque les
sciences c'est une vérité fondamentale
la gravité et la même que vous soyez à
Détroit Bangkok ou Singapour alors que
là finalement on pourrait vous dire non
la pomme ne tombe pas la même vitesse
sur chaque continent vous pensez que la
terre est plate ou effectivement que la
terre est plate et soutient une tortue
qui avance sur l'univers comme certains
le pensent
pas vrai pédagogie ce soir je reviens
effectivement et c'est 100% d'accord
avec cette histoire de la temporalité
des sciences c'est vrai que Marie Curie
Louis Pasteur c'est facile aujourd'hui
de les mettre sur un piédestal parce que
qu'est-ce que l'on a deux aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les résultats le positif sur
des dizaines de d'années de recherche on
n'a pas vécu ce temps de la science et
on a fait beaucoup de pédagogie au
niveau des sciences au niveau de la
médecine ces trois dernières années mais
on n'a pas appris à comment recevoir ce
genre d'information et de se rendre
compte que finalement une information a
donné le 7 janvier qui nous dit ça n'est
pas aéroporté et notre information qui
nous dit le 12 février si finalement ça
est reporté il faut commencer à mettre
le masque ça ne veut pas dire qu'on a
essayé duper quelqu'un ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on avait par raison d'un côté ou
de l'autre ça veut dire que la science
elle se nourrit de nouvelles
informations de nouvelles découvertes et
que et automatiquement chaque fois il
faut remettre en cause tout ce qu'on
avait mis en place parce que la science
et là c'est le vivant d'autant plus donc
c'est d'autant plus dynamique échangeant
et il faut se réadapter à chaque fois
alors on va ensuite vraiment anglaise
sur la crise covid mais encore une
question de cadrage avec vous pierre
est-ce que pas un phénomène généralisé
une forme de crise de confiance en
général qui touche tout le monde parce
que quand on regarde la part des
Français qui font confiance à la science
et rester élevée quand même on va pas
non plus faire une émission dramatise
les choses à dessin non les Français ont
encore largement la majoritairement
confiance en leur en la science mais
cette part baisse c'est ça c'est ça le
souci mais quand on regarde en
comparatif et ben les scientifiques
restent quand même loin devant les
politiques les PDG et puis on va venir
peut-être les journalistes non mais vous
avez tout à fait raison moi j'étais
vacciné très rapidement aujourd'hui je
suis la quatrième dos je le dis pour
l'été spectateurs ce que c'est le moment
c'est maintenant quand la vaccination
par par l'ARN est apparu je ne
connaissais pas le processus et moi j'ai
fait confiance en institution parce que
je savais qu'au sein de l'institution il
y avait des gens qui pouvaient m'assurer
que tout le processus avait été fait de
façon tout à fait efficace mais cette
crise de confiance elle touche toutes
les paroles tout ce qui vient de d'en
haut bien sûr mais mais mes collègues
sénateurs quand ils ont vu Raoul sur le
plateau ils ont été rassurés finalement
en se disant que il y avait un niveau de
détestation du scientifique Raoul qui
peuvent être supérieures à ce qui vivait
sur le terrain voilà donc moi je trouve
pas ça rassurant mais mais je crois que
ça participe d'une forme de défiance
généralisée vis-à-vis des politiques
vis-à-vis des partis politiques c'est
pas parler les partis politiques alors
je crois qu'on doit être au départ
d'entreprise bien sûr et de la science
en général et donc des journalistes qui
doivent aussi se remettre en cause parce
qu'on fait partie de nous tous nous ici
alors on essaie de faire du mieux qu'on
peut mais voilà on a la parole
journalistique et le site touchée par ce
discrédit généraliser oui mais
s'agissant des sciences je pense qu'il y
a une cerise sur le gâteau il y a un
problème supplémentaire qui vient
s'enchasser sur les autres c'est que la
science est ghettoïsée dans les médias
il y a extrêmement peu de parole
scientifiques dans les médias alors
évidemment il y a les médias de
référence il y a les grands journaux du
etc qui on sent que tu arrivais la place
de la science mais finalement la presse
qui est vue la presse qui est vue les
télés les radios combien d'effectifs de
journalistes scientifiques peuvent-elles
compter extrêmement peu la crise va un
peu monter avec la graisse en tout cas à
ce moment-là beaucoup de médias ont posé
le doigt sur le problème on dit on peut
plus continuer comme ça mais ce que
j'aimerais bien savoir c'est combien
parmi eux ont effectivement engagé les
scientifiques les journalistes qui
manquaient à leurs effectifs je pense
que les chiffres seront
significativement très très bas ce
problème de culture vous savez par
exemple très français on va personne ne
va dire ne me parlait pas de Victor Hugo
je veux pas entendre parler ça ne
m'intéresse pas par contre les maths ou
les maths c'est pas pour moi la physique
quantique ouh là là je vais être perdue
etc ça c'est un c'est une sorte de
pédanterie contre laquelle il faudrait
aller et ça va vous avez utilisé le mot
de pédagogie la pédagogie la
responsabilité des médias c'est de
montrer comme ça a été dit dans le sujet
que les sciences les sciences pas
quelque chose qu'il faut poser à côté et
sur lesquels on va aller voir de temps
en temps pour se distraire la science a
infuse dans toutes les partout dans
notre société
et donc ça devrait être traité comme tel
dans les médias oui mais moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on a on a du mal aussi à
s'adresser à des gens qui pourraient
douter mais qui pourraient être
convaincu c'est à dire qu'on a d'un coup
on a soit les prociences absolues soit
les antivax et on a du mal à avoir un
discours pour des gens qui doutent et
qui ont besoin d'être convaincus par des
éléments c'est vrai que le vaccin ça
fait peur quand il est développé très
rapidement on se pose des questions et
comme on les met tout de suite dans les
antivax dans les complotistes on les
braque un petit peu il me semble on pose
des étiquettes un peu sur les gens alors
à qui les kaki la faute on va essayer de
réfléchir puis surtout on va essayer de
penser aussi à des solutions et un des
exemples les plus récents évidemment
c'est cette ou cette défiance a pu se
manifester c'est la crise covid d'une
maladie inédite une peur mondiale et
vous en disiez un mot tout à l'heure un
de ces métiers où bien entendu un petit
peu tout est son contraire en gros tous
les ingrédients étaient réunis pour pour
cette petite crise de défiance et non
pas de de confiance les médecins des
scientifiques portent une part de
responsabilité pour vous il y a toute
une temporalité aussi de 2020 fait en
sorte que en amont il y a il s'est passé
tout plein de choses qui fait que
aujourd'hui c'était mature surtout sur
une pandémie pour prendre une importance
telle il y a un péché originel autour de
l'an 2000 d'une étude sur le vaccin
trivalent de la rougeole qui était censé
générer l'autisme chez les chez les
enfants vaccinés c'est une étude qui a
été publiée par the landset et comme
disait tout à l'heure c'est un peu la
bible de la médecine et finalement il
s'est avéré que cette étude ensuite a
été retirée et invalidée parce que la
méthode n'était pas bonne et que le
docteur en question avait des intérêts
financiers justement dans le fait de
démontrer que alors on va venir tout ça
c'est très intéressant ce que vous dites
la question des vaccins c'est vrai où il
y avait des germes si j'ose dire qui
était déjà posées avant avant ce sur le
covid et puis la question des conflits
d'intérêts aussi mais je reviens quand
même à ma question est-ce que les
scientifiques les médecins ont parlé
trop vite trop tôt à tort et à travers
en direct alors c'était pas leur rôle
pendant la pandémie pendant le
déclenchement et la poursuite du temps
scientifique tout à l'heure est-ce que
vous disiez essayer était très vrai
aussi c'est à dire la validation par les
Pères et aujourd'hui pendant cette covid
on a sacrifié ça sur l'hôtel de la crise
sanitaire et de l'urgence de du moment
et du coup il y a eu beaucoup
d'informations qui sont sorties avant
même que les articles soient relus
confirmés et validés et finalement ça
s'est fait sur la place publique même si
ça a été invalidé deux jours plus tard
finalement ça n'a plus d'importance
parce que à partir du moment
on est aussi encore une fois c'est
c'était pas pour disgraisser sur cette
histoire de Lancet mais c'est que entre
temps on a aussi vécu l'avènement de
l'Internet médias sociaux ou tout le
monde justement est en mesure de pouvoir
donner son avis et on tombe un peu dans
la croyance et et plus dans
l'aspect scientifique et finalement à
partir du moment où une information est
libérée sur les réseaux sociaux elle va
très très vite et une étude a sorti
l'année dernière que une fausse rumeur
médicale une fausse rumeur tout court
d'ailleurs les fake news circulaient six
fois plus vite qu'une vérité voulait pas
dire que des scientifiques se sont
trompés ou des médecins sont trompés
scientifiques se trompent tous les jours
enfin c'est ça la science c'est ça la
science en fait essayer la science est
essayé donc ça marche parfois ça marche
pas mais quand ça ne marche pas mais on
continue d'avancer mais ça ça se fait
dans les laboratoires dans les études
dans les expériences et une fois que
après tâtonnement de tâtonnement on dit
tiens là j'ai un résultat je vais le
présenter à mes paires parce que c'est
quoi la science la science c'est un
résultat reproductible peu importe qui
est derrière les manettes et peu importe
où ça se trouve donc il faut aussi
confirmer cela mais si on sort un
résultat juste avant mais finalement on
ne peut pas avoir confirmation de ce
fait établi scientifique donc oui en
fait on a eu un mix de Stans
scientifique de la libération de la
parole de effectivement les anti-ciances
les prouces les conflits et politiques
aussi parce que dans certains pays la
crise sanitaire a été gérée à travers
les différents partis les Etats-Unis par
exemple le Brésil également et
finalement on a tout plein de facteurs
qui amènent à aujourd'hui cette
déchéance alors elle est pas
catastrophique cette déchéance mais elle
est suffisamment importante parce que
qui sont ces personnes qui ont cette
défiance et ceux qui vont être le plus
investis pour justement porter la parole
ceux qui ont confiance ne passe pas leur
vie sur internet j'ai confiance le
vaccin est tout bon on parlait de
médecin on parlait scientifique on va
évidemment parler d'une figure de cette
période coïn mais oui mais professeur
des antivacs ce professeur Raoul tout le
monde se souvient de cet homme
charismatique aux allures de prophètes
barbus cheveux longs grande gueule qui
s'est imposé rapidement dans les débats
publics on va
donc démarche 2020 il s'imposent avec
son remède miracle à base d'hydroxyde
chloroquine une potion magique un élixir
digne d'une BD de Lucky Luke qui
habituellement pour soigner ouais c'est
ça il faut soigner le paludisme donc le
chercheur estime que c'est bon pourquoi
combattre le covid et il présente pas
forcément d'études en bonne et due forme
alors il profite du flou artistique qui
caractérisait le début de la crise
sanitaire et de sa gestion par le
gouvernement on se souvient de sibet
Ndiaye qui nous expliquait l'inutilité
du masque au tout début et le
scientifique a vite réussi à convaincre
bon nombre de citoyens mais aussi des
personnalités publiques et même des
politiques parmi elles Christian Estrosi
le maire de Nice avait lui-même testé le
traitement préconisé par Raoul il
concluait très sérieusement j'ai fait
confiance à ce médecin et je vais bien
il faut faire confiance aux professeur
raout Emmanuel Macron lui-même s'était
rendu à Marseille en avril 2020 une
façon de montrer qu'il écoutait au delà
du conseil scientifique mais c'était une
manière aussi de légitimité de légitimer
quelque part la parole du professeur
raout et face à la polémique qui enflait
Macron a fait de nouveau le déplacement
en septembre 2021 là il est plus prudent
il prend sa défense tout en maintenant
une certaine prudence le professeur
Raoul était un grand scientifique dit-il
mais même s'il faut admettre que ces
prises de parole ont pu conduire à des
réticences envers le vaccin comment ça
explique ce succès du professeur
raoulité du cafouillage un petit peu
dont on parlait en matière scientifique
et gouvernementale voilà il en a rajouté
on a remis en question on l'a dit la
parole des institutions publiques des
autorités scientifiques il a pas il a
pas hésité aussi à utiliser son autorité
de chercheurs et même son autorité
naturelle tout court on va écouter ses
réponses quand il est auditionné le 15
septembre 2020 par
on ne peut pas me retrouver à discuter
avec des gens qui font une tribune en
disant que je fraude et que je triche en
mettant leur nom et ensuite faire une
discussion avec il y a une limite c'est
plus des discussions scientifiques un a
d'autres qui ont porté plainte auprès de
moi auprès du Conseil de l'Ordre et vous
comprendrez bien que
limite c'est une limite à ma
convivialité je ne suis pas d'accord du
tout avec vous bien sûr sur aucun des
points le premier point le premier point
c'est que la question est pas une
question ce n'est pas un débat entre
nous si vous vous avez des affirmations
avec lequel je suis en total des accords
donc à ces musclé et Raoul assume aussi
ses contre-vérités assurant des volts
face au moment propice il s'en fiche
complètement en février la sûr que le
virus ne fera pas plus de morts que les
accidents de trottinette donc très peu
en mai 2020 il dit qu'il n'y aura pas de
deuxième vague ça c'est en mai 2020 car
en juin de la même année il décrète un
nouveau pic et épidémique donc j'en
passe et des meilleurs résultats les
enquêtes judiciaires d'administratives
se multiplient même sa fille spécialiste
en médecine vasculaire prend des
distances elle porte plainte contre un
de ses collaborateurs pour diffamations
en septembre 2020 T1 il est remplacé
depuis le premier septembre 2022 à 70
ans il est revenu à son métier
d'enseignant en fait on peut dire que
son ouvrage qui est paru en janvier 2022
résume assez bien la brèche dans
laquelle il s'est engouffré son titre
c'est chronique pour une humanité en
quête de repère mais c'était pas
forcément des repères scientifiques qui
me proposaient
la science des mauvais génies il y a
ça c'est pour la partie scientifique il
y en a eu aussi un peu côté politique
ils sont peut-être responsables aussi je
pense à une petite phrase de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur le le vaccin et surgelés
je choisis une en souvenez un vaccin qui
se fabrique à moins 60 vous et moi si on
y connaît rien en vaccin on connaît au
moins deux ou trois trucs sur le
surgelés puisqu'on en consomme ce vaccin
qui dépend d'une telle chaîne du froid
et bien il m'inquiète est-ce que c'est
bien responsable c'est bien responsable
non alors sur sur Raoul moi je suis très
reconnaissant c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
beaucoup aidé parce qu'il se trouve que
au même moment pour l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques par
rapport voilà avec le député Pierre
Henri on avait fait un rapport sur
l'intégrité scientifique alors
dites-nous pour les tests spectateurs
qu'est-ce que l'intégrité scientifique
c'est c'est faire que des chercheurs et
des droits bien évidemment mais aussi
des devoirs et le devoir c'est de
respecter scrupuleusement les protocoles
scientifiques les protocoles
expérimentaux de satisfaire
des pères de publier de façon correcte
etc c'est ce que font la grande masse
des chercheurs vous pensez vous direz
quel diagnostic vous posez la grande
masse mais il y a des tricheurs il y a
des tricheur pour bien sûr totalement
malheureusement c'était connu très
longue date parce que quand vous êtes
chercheur et que vous publiez deux
articles par semaine on peut avoir un
doute quand même sur la qualité de ce
que vous publiez donc c'est une petite
entreprise
c'était tout son laboratoire qui était
derrière la machine à produire du papier
et lui signer ce qui est ce qui est des
pratiques qui sont tout à fait
condamnables donc ça c'est c'est
déviance là ça nous a permis à nous
sénateurs d'introduire dans la loi des
dispositifs sur la fraude scientifique
qui sont aujourd'hui reconnues comme les
plus protecteurs au monde donc vous
voyez à toute chose malheur est bon
voilà donc ça nous a permis de ça sur
les politiques même chose tout le monde
sait improvisé un peu épidémiologie
c'est ça ça fait mal de chien aux
épidémiologistes et ce qui ce qui a
changé c'est la starification de la
science avant quand vous étiez
scientifiques vous communiquiez par
votre laboratoire par l'arcmission par
des organes de médiation et là des gens
qui étaient en mal de notoriété ce sont
adressés à la totalité de l'humanité on
oubliant ce qui était leur règle
déontologique donc ça c'est des choses
que aujourd'hui on doit sanctionner et
la loi le permet Olivier lesquar je
parle pas de vous en particulier un nid
bien sûr de français à venir mais est-ce
que voilà les journalistes ont aussi une
responsabilité dans dans cette crise
coïn d'avoir peut-être parfois monter en
épingle des des phénomènes scientifiques
qui n'en n'étaient pas ou cette
improvisé eux-mêmes un médecin difficile
de refaire le match quelques années plus
tard mais encore une fois il faut faire
une différence entre les médias tous les
journalistes ne font pas leur métier de
la même façon et
des journalistes par exemple d'un organe
comme Sciences et Avenir ce sont des
gens qui eux-mêmes ont un bagage
scientifique assez sophistiqué donc ils
ne vont pas interroger un spécialiste de
l'immunologie comme ils vont interroger
un épidémiologue ils savent que le même
ne va pas avoir les mêmes types de
réponse dans les médias tout terrain
dans lesquels les il n'y avait pas ce
casting des bons journalistes à partir
du moment où quelqu'un travaillait dans
le domaine de la santé on a pu le sortir
du lot et s'il passait bien à la télé on
lui a fait dire ce qu'il pouvait être de
nature à faire la bonne phrase qui
ensuite serait reprise sur les réseaux
sociaux donc effectivement les
journalistes ont commis des erreurs même
nous dire on a traité en temps réel de
cette crise on a eu jusqu'à 17 millions
de visiteurs sur le site de Sciences et
Avenir mensuellement donc c'est
considérable et on a pu faire des
erreurs évidemment mais disons qu'on a
approché le sujet avec toute la
déontologie et la méthode qui est
absolument vitale dans des cas comme
cela parce que il est question de vie ou
de mort s'agissant de Raoult ce qui se
passe aussi c'est que c'est
les médias ont besoin de l'art du récit
maintenant on utilise le terme de
personnage c'était un sacré panoramique
on avait la formule globale on avait le
personnage avec sa trogne on avait la
formule magique de la potion avec
l'hydroxychloroquine on avait le seul
contre tous voilà
c'était merveilleux d'un point de vue de
la narration et il a prospéré il a
prospéré là-dessus il venait aussi vous
dire tout le monde savait etc mais
c'était quand même un personnage qui
dirigeait
une référence
elle avait quand même un CV il a quand
même un CV long comme le bras donc c'est
des protections politiques si vous
voulez il y a des imposteurs qui dans
leur garage du jour au lendemain nous
disent j'ai trouvé la solution pour
faire la fusion froide bon là on n'avait
pas la même typologie de personnage donc
c'est beaucoup plus délicat et quand
évidemment on a quelqu'un qui a une bon
c'est plus difficile parce que quand
face à lui il a des journalistes qui
savent pas du tout et qui étaient à
l'économie ou au foot et qu'on leur
demande de traiter le covid c'est
dramatique donc ça pose un question sur
l'économie de la presse quoi c'est vrai
alors la critique de la science et c'est
cristallisée sur la question des vaccins
notamment pendant la crise covid même si
la remise en cause de la vaccination et
vous nous en avons tout à l'heure ne
date pas d'hier mais c'est plus long il
y a cette affaire de rougeole que vous
citiez il y a peut-être aussi l'hépatite
B si on va aller plus loin finalement la
première succès de la vaccination c'est
toutes ces maladies infantiles qu'on a
réussi à à ne pas éradiquer mais à
diminuer dans les pays dans tous les
pays du monde on a eu l'éradication de
la variole ce premier succès derrière
lequel on a lancé l'éradications de la
polio et ça fait 32 ans aujourd'hui
qu'on essaye on a un vaccin qui
fonctionne et on est toujours pas arrivé
à éradiquer la polio pourquoi parce
qu'il y a une crise de confiance sur
avec les vaccins quand est-ce qu'elle
apparaît
dans les années 2000 en fait il y a
plusieurs aspects il y a effectivement
ce qu'on venait de parler tout à l'heure
cette cette enquête enfin pas cette
enquête cette étude qui mettait un doute
l'émergence de facebook d'Internet qui a
été une caisse de résonance très
importante et finalement l'invalidation
de l'étude par le 27 n'a pas suffi
justement à terre c'est doute et
finalement ça a fait un petit peu tâche
d'huile ici et là jusqu'au point où la
rougeole a repris de l'ampleur partout
dans le monde derrière ça qu'on se méfie
des labos non avec les scandales
sanitaires qu'on peut on a pu avoir
alors je parlais du vaccin sur
l'hépatite B qui était pas certain
des choses comme ça ça tout ce qui vient
de l'industrie pharmaceutique et objet
de suspicion aujourd'hui
disons qu'on est partagé entre
finalement la suspicion qui est
insufflée par justement toute cette
pression autour de la défiance de la
croyance justement et plus du fait
scientifique et en même temps comment
voulez-vous que quelqu'un qui n'est pas
dans le domaine de la recherche de la
vaccination puisse savoir finalement si
ce qu'on lui dit est vrai ou pas parce
que ce que vous disiez sur les
journalistes est vrai aussi dans la
population générale on a quelques bases
de sciences on a quelques bases de de
connaissances médicales mais en même
temps quand on nous dit ben tiens à la
RNM c'est un petit messager qui va venir
et générer des morceaux pour faire de la
vaccination mais en zoom oui mais
finalement est-ce que ça ne pourrait pas
faire autre chose alors je vous arrête
parce qu'on va en parler tout de suite
de ça avec avec Steve Jourdain j'espère
à bien travailler son sujet et à pas
fait voilà parce que accompagne
n'importe quoi sur la science la crise
coïn a donné naissance à toute une série
fake news sur sur Steve parmi les
aberrations entendues il y avait cette
fameuse histoire de de plus 5 g c'est ça
la flottabilité aurait eu l'intention de
nous implanter des puces 5G avec le
vaccin contre le covid c'était une
fausse information qui circulait
beaucoup à l'époque sur les réseaux le
confondateur de Microsoft aurait créé le
virus de toutes pièces pour prendre le
contrôle de la population mondiale en
nous injectant des puces de
géolocalisation c'est évidemment une
fake news
et cette pile notamment sur le fait que
la Fondation guys la Fondation Bill et
Melinda guess a mis de l'argent pour
développer un vaccin contre le covid
depuis janvier 2020 la Fondation a donné
plus de 2 milliards de dollars aux
différents instituts et laboratoires de
recherche et puis on précise en passant
qu'il est techniquement impossible
d'injecter un traceur GPS par
l'intermédiaire d'un vaccin alors autre
rumeur le vaccin contre le covid va nous
modifier génétiquement ça c'est ce
qu'avant c'est une ancienne chercheuse
de l'Inserm dont on ne citera pas le nom
par charité chrétienne ou par prévention
mais
c'était pas la seule un certain médecin
controversé ou affirmé effectivement que
le vaccin ARN messager et bien sa
parenté à un traitement on a entendu que
le vaccin contribue à modifier nos gènes
c'est une théorie évidemment
complètement fausse elle est fondée sur
une mauvaise compréhension du
fonctionnement de l'ARN messager cette
technologie qui a déboulé dans nos vies
à l'occasion de la pandémie en fait il
s'agit d'un code transmis à nos cellules
qui permet de demander à notre système
immunitaire de fabriquer certaines
protéines mais il n'y a pas de
modification d'une noyau de nos cellules
et donc pas de transformation de notre
patrimoine génétique monsieur autre
humeur de toute façon les labos ne sont
pas responsables en cas d'effets
secondaires les fabricants de vaccins
n'auraient aucun compte à rendre en cas
d'effet indésirables c'est une fake news
qui a même été colportée par certains
responsables politiques Marine Le Pen
pour pas la cité en fait la Commission
européenne l'a rappelé à plusieurs
reprises oui l'élaboratoires restent
responsables en cas d'effets secondaires
c'est une règle générale qui s'applique
aussi au vaccin contre le covid Matthieu
on vaccine on vaccine mais le virus ne
tue pas ça aussi une petite musique le
vaccin serait simplement destiné à faire
gonfler le chiffre d'affaires de
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est une
idée qui a beaucoup circulé et qui
circulent encore d'ailleurs sur les
réseaux sociaux on rappelle que le covid
a officiellement tué plus de 6 millions
de personnes à travers le monde plus de
2 millions rien qu'en Europe 160 000
personnes sont mortes en France depuis
2020 et alors où on se parle au covid
continuer la semaine dernière on a
comptabilisé plus de 400 décès en 7
jours dans l'Hexagone bref vaccinez-vous
faites le rappel c'est important Mathieu
merci beaucoup Steve parmi les autres
motifs peut-être de cette de cette crise
de défiance il y a il y a la question
vous parliez de l'intégrité scientifique
mais cette question aussi des conflits
d'intérêts qui a pu nette entre la
science le traditionnellement le secteur
public et le secteur privé
de quand date cette suspicion et comment
la combat elle date d'une transformation
du manque de financement de la recherche
publique qui privait de ressources est
allé chercher à l'extérieur et notamment
vers les grandes entreprises
pharmaceutiques les moyens d'assurer de
leur recherche donc les les chercheurs
ont été obligés d'aller chercher leurs
fonds ailleurs et ils se sont trouvés
naturellement en conflit d'intérêt donc
moi je je défends des fonctionnaires qui
fonctionnent qui travaillent qui font de
la recherche avec des crédits publics
parce que c'est ce qui permet leur
véritable indépendance et ce qui permet
aux politiques ensuite d'être assurés de
leur expertise complètement indépendante
il faut rejeter par principe
cofinancement de recherche
mais il faut considérer que sur certains
domaines clés l'État doit mettre les
moyens pour s'assurer que l'expertise
est totalement ind parce que c'est ce
qui lui donne de la valeur et notamment
pour les politiques pas partout mais on
choisit des domaines où on dit ben voilà
sur la vaccination on veut remettre en
place toute une filière
financée sur sur fonds publics et ça je
pense que c'est important on a besoin de
ça parce que pour le coup on a eu des
histoires de cofinance mais bien sûr
pour la vaccination il faut rappeler
quand même bien sûr absolument
incroyable scientifique mais tous les
chercheurs sont conflit d'intérêt parce
que ils obligent à aller chercher de
l'argent ailleurs
la science est en fait il faut il faut
réintroduire le principe de réalité la
science tout n'est pas beau et tout
n'est pas merveilleux parce que tout
simplement ça s'inscrit un petit peu
dans le fonctionnement du monde donc il
y a de la science qui a envie de faire
avancer les choses on parlait de progrès
je pense qu'il faut redéfinir progrès
aussi dans ces dernières années et puis
ensuite effectivement pourquoi on va
chercher des financements dans le privé
et pourquoi justement les intérêts
économiques viennent privilégier les
intérêts de santé publique et du
bien-être de tous parce que il y a pas
de financement aujourd'hui
la Fondation Bill et Mélinda Gates
c'était le deuxième contributeur de
l'OMS tout simplement parce que les
États eux-mêmes avec leur contribution
pourtant obligatoire n'amenez pas assez
d'argent pour permettre le
fonctionnement de l'OMS et c'est la même
chose finalement dans on a parlé encore
une fois de cette fondation gate qui
travaille énormément avec les
vaccinations en Afrique mais parce que
aussi il y a un désinvestissements de la
santé parce qu'elle est considérée comme
un coût et pas comme un investissement
en France aussi la santé est considérée
comme un coup ça fait combien d'années
qu'on dit que l'hôpital est en
déshérence on l'a tellement dit souvent
de fois qu'on l'écoute même plus mais
aujourd'hui on a nos trois épidémies
bronchiolites grippe covid on a un
hôpital exsang qui arrête pas de crier
qu'ils n'ont plus de budget ils se font
attaquer pour se faire en sonner 10
millions d'euros ou de dollars pour
avoir ne pas se faire remballer les
données de santé sur sur la place
publique aujourd'hui on manque vraiment
d'investissement envers la santé envers
la médecine mais de la part de du public
de la part de l'État tique de l'OMS et
de toutes les institutions
gouvernementales
comme au niveau national parce qu'il
faut expliquer aussi il y a parfois
poussé un peu la roue dans j'allais dire
du mauvais côté avec la propagande faut
le dire je pense au sol dépensé par
l'industrie du tabac notamment
américaine
ou ce qu'a fait les industries des
énergies fossiles pour nous dire qu'il y
avait pas tellement de réchauffement
climatique il y a quand même une part de
chercheurs qui se sont prêtés il y a ces
études ou je sais pas si c'est des
fausses études ou des vraies études ou
télécommandées comme on peut dire à
l'arrivée c'est quand même de la fausse
science puisque c'est de la science
financée pour le principe de la science
c'est qu'on ne sait pas quel est le
résultat qu'on va obtenir et là c'est un
résultat qui est télécommandé en quelque
sorte donc des personnes malhonnêtes
existent dans tous les corps de métiers
et des scientifiques malhonnêtes comme
cela comme ce que vous venez de citer ça
ça a pu exister et ça existe encore
malheureusement donc il y a des il y a
des conflits d'intérêts il y a les liens
d'intérêt qui sont encore autre chose
comment les règles ces deux questions
vous pouvez expliquer aux États conflit
d'intérêt il y a intérêt c'est pas le
lien d'intérêt aujourd'hui un chercheur
peut être invité à prendre la parole
dans un colloque il peut être invité à
déplacement alors pas forcément sous les
tropiques mais on peut rencontrer des
gens intéressants aussi sous les
tropiques pourquoi pas mais en tout cas
des prises de parole comme ça qui sont
payées par une puissance invitante et il
faut le déclarer et ça va pas infuser
sur ces recherches dans d'autres c'est
la réglementation oblige les chercheurs
à déclarer il faut le redire aussi au
téléspectateurs c'est aller
scientifiques font pas n'importe quoi
n'importe où n'importe non absolument
pas absolument pas et en revanche il y a
aussi des des gens il y a eu une affaire
avec totale il y a quelques temps aussi
avec un chercheur dont on s'est rendu
compte qu'il était financé par Total et
pendant des années il avait dit que les
effets du réchauffement climatique était
pas si important que ça donc ça ça
existe il y a un point que j'aimerais
bien sur lequel j'aimerais bien revenir
peut-être on a parlé beaucoup des fake
news et de la façon dont elle se
diffusait abondamment avec le web et
avec les réseaux sociaux donc moi je
défends un peu ma paroisse vous allez
dire puisque
les réseaux sociaux et Twitter notamment
a été aussi un accélérateur de science
pendant le covid c'est-à-dire qu'on a
essayé d'expliquer comment la science se
faisait avec des revues par les Pères
une validation très très longue très
très longue qui peut prendre des années
pendant le covid comme on était dans
l'urgence les papiers on parle de
préprint c'est-à-dire d'articles qui
n'ont pas encore eu cette validation
était publiée directement sur Internet
et la discussion se faisait
ouvert en ligne donc de cela il a pu
aussi ressortir des choses très très
positives des choses négatives aussi
parce que cette exposition a fait que
des études qui n'étaient pas encore
validées ont pu accrocher la lumière et
on a pu en parler alors que c'était un
mauvais escient mais à d'autres moments
ça a permis de faire de la science à
ciel ouvert
la boîte aux algorithmes et on le dit
souvent à Sens public les réseaux
sociaux sont surtout des outils après
l'usage qu'on en fait peut être mauvais
ou bon mais voilà essaie c'est vrai
qu'en l'occurrence ça a été un
accélérateur sur les réseaux sociaux à
la fois des mauvaises infos comme des
bonnes infos juste est-ce que est-ce
qu'au fond la façon de résoudre c'est
pas d'avoir un problème d'éducation et
de culture scientifique au sens large
pour la fois les enfants et même pour
une partie du personnel politique de
morale et d'éthique aussi qu'est-ce que
c'est des choses qu'on oublie un peu
aujourd'hui alors de morale et des
tiques de la part des émetteurs
d'information scientifique de tout le
monde et puis même de ceux qui reçoivent
l'information aussi c'est-à-dire qui je
pense que ce qui est tout à fait
essentiel notamment à l'école c'est
refonder un sens critique
aujourd'hui on est complètement
submergé par l'information et ce qu'il
faut faire notamment à l'école c'est
apprendre aux enfants de trouver des
moyens pour sélectionner les
informations et essayer de les vérifier
par par d'autres c'est à dire faire par
rapport aux réseaux sociaux ce que vous
journaliste vous faites par rapport à
l'information l'information des réseaux
sociaux elle est non traitée donc il
faut vérifier il faut la croiser il faut
pas la prendre comme une chance infuse
au contraire ce qui est important c'est
l'esprit critique ça c'est fondamental
même pour les politiques ça peut la
responsabilité des politiques elle est
énorme parce que monsieur le sénateur et
l'arbre qui cachent la forêt et quand il
dit tout à l'heure il y a deux
chercheurs dans l'hémicycle c'est
une catastrophe le personnel politique
français ne s'intéresse pas aussi et il
n'a pas on a une ministre de la Santé
on a eu Madame Merkel et Madame Merkel
en Allemagne qui était physicienne de
formation qui avait le bagage qui lui
permettait d'aborder des sujets à
thématiques scientifiques et
technologiques avec voilà le recul et
les techniciens oui mais on a quelques
exemples qui sont assez vrai que Madame
borne et politique
[Musique]
peut-être qu'il y a eu aussi des manques
parce que vous dites oui l'éducation
mais sur la communication sur la
vaccination même encore aujourd'hui pour
rendre plus clair faire comprendre ce
que c'est exactement montrer les riches
ou pas il y a eu quand même des effets
secondaires qui ont été mentionnés mais
beaucoup plus tardivement donc on a
besoin on a envie de savoir c'est vrai
que les citoyens sont informés sur tout
ça et pour revenir sur le financement je
pense qu'on a vu que l'Europe avait un
rôle important pour les masques pour
tout ça et probablement elle pourrait
avoir un rôle important sur le
financement même si c'est pas tout à
fait dans ses compétences à l'heure
actuelle pour finir hansenek est-ce que
est-ce que l'essentiel aussi à faire
comprendre aux gens c'est que le temps
scientifique est un temps particulier le
temps scientifique
qui n'est pas un temps politique c'est
pas un temps de l'immédiateté en
l'occurrence il faut le voir de
l'extérieur c'est à dire prendre du
recul et effectivement là on est dans
une réponse où ici et maintenant on fait
face à la situation mais après
finalement la situation avancée pour
revenir sur ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure je pense qu'il est aussi
important de faire la différence entre
un message scientifique et un marketing
agressif et pathogène où on a pu
justement voir des messages d'industriel
vantant la cigarette
vantant les bénéfices qui pouvaient
faire d'avoir une voiture qui leur
apportait la liberté et ainsi de suite
donc il y a plusieurs chemins qui sont
possibles pour pour améliorer cette
compréhension et essayer de faire les
bons choix au bon moment et puis
renforcer on le dira jamais si assez sur
ce plateau l'éducation scientifique bien
sûr de nos enfants mais aussi des
concitoyens et donc
invitons tout le monde à lire la presse
scientifique est de vulgarisation
scientifiques n'est pas un gros mot la
vulgarisation scientifique au contraire
ça permet de comprendre le monde qui
nous entoure et ses enjeux merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat passionnant
alors on n'a pas tout résolu on a essayé
de poser en tout cas quelques éléments
qui nous permettront développer
peut-être votre esprit critique c'est
Philippe juin qui sera demain l'invité
de la matinale de Public Sénat députés
LR et chef des urgences à l'hôpital
Georges Pompidou merci à tous d'avoir
suivi cette émission et à bientôt